Steven Shea, Filmmaker [SURVIVING SUPERCON]:
So there's a part in the middle of the movie
where the screen goes blank and it's like
“Oh no, the tingler is loose in the theater!”
Film Courage: Why do you say that all creatives
have a creature living inside of them?
Steven: Did I say that yeah it
sounds like something I would say.
Film Courage: you said it was like this creature
that was always like oh we could do that oh and I
can make that and it's it can be a blessing and
a curse and and the curse is it won't leave you
alone because you you're always thinking of these
new ideas and how you want to like make something
yeah I really love this movie The Tingler [1959]
that is a William Castle film starring Vincent
Price where Vincent Price is a scientist that
discovers that fear is a creature that lives on
your spinal cord and the creature gets bigger and
bigger it feeds off your fear and the only way to
shrink the creature back down is by screaming
and the whole movie is about this they get a
mute girl who can't scream and they scare her
to force this creature to break out and then the
creature gets loose so they can try to experiment
with the creature but I always really enjoyed that
premise because I feel that's the same way with
creativity you have a monster living inside you
that is so desperate to do things creatively and
this goes back to passion versus obsession too
because it's like you go to bed sometimes like
I have an idea oh my gosh this is a great idea
I gotta write this down I gotta figure out a way
to do this I gotta pitch it to somebody I gotta
see about it it's like a madness that I feel like
kind of lives inside and everyone has a bit of a
multiple personalities right so you have this
creature that lives inside of you that's just
whispering these great ideas in your ear
you're like oh yeah that is a good idea
oh I could totally do that oh I could change
this or blah blah and so I i like the whole idea
that you have a friend that's with you you know so
it's just yeah so your creativity is this creature
that lives inside of you that that is constantly
forcing you to get excited about things and then
trying to figure out how to accomplish them but
it's it's it is a bit of madness it does drive you
crazy sometimes because not everyone can just go
out and make whatever they want at all times not
not decently and there's certain projects that you
want to wait until you can do them correctly or
hopefully do them correctly or get the right
kind of budget you need or the right team
and so I think that every I mean every creative
is a little bit mad of course but it's almost
as if it's coming from somewhere else it's
not really you I mean I feel like everyone
talks to themselves everyone has conversations
in their head oh yeah absolutely who are you
talking to it's just you there's no one else in
there right or is there someone else in there
so I always loved that movie identity where they
have the guy who's kind of a spoiler I guess
but has all the different personalities that
persona that turn into people and it's all the
different elements of his personality all these
different people and they're all different but
you know everyone works better in groups
right we we like to work in groups we like
to work in teams it makes things easier
so the idea that you have me myself and I
your your trinity inside of you that's all
working together to to make things happen I
think is a comforting feeling to where the world
isn't always 100 on your shoulders even though it
seems like it because you have you yourself and I
to to help out you know and your little creative
monster that lives that lives in your spinal
cord it helps it helps lift that weight because
being in an entertainment you know we have a very
big responsibility and you look at things like
the great depression you look at the history
of movies in the great depression all movies
turned to comedy because people desperately
needed a way to escape how tragic reality
was and we've had that same thing happen this
past year with covet people are trapped at home
well Netflix numbers are skyrocketing because
they're stuck at home they need that escape
they need entertainment to survive and I
really think that it's it's important you
know what we do it's not just for fun and
giggles and it seems like it to some people
but it is really important because a lot of
people's livelihood it this this helps them
it's their escape from reality it helps keep them
sane so their monsters don't get loose on them and
and i'm really proud to be a part of all
that especially when you can provide someone
entertainment with your with your work
I mean that's an amazing amazing feeling
what year did that movie come out with Vincent
Price oh gosh 60s okay i'm not sure the exact year
and what's the title of it again it's called the
tingler the tingler that's right you said that
it was it was a William Castle movie and
they put buzzers all around the theater
so there's a part in the middle of the
movie where the screen goes blank and
it's like oh no The Tingler is on loose in
the theater and just starts shocking people
people are screaming and jumping up and
running around and yeah that's a good one
so the only negative to having this creature
and this metaphorical creature inside of you
is that it's frustrating because you can't
get all of the projects you want done
well it's hungry you know it's a hungry creature
and if it's not fed it gets angry and I ended up
starting in video and then a few years later
I ended up getting into photography because I
was like oh photography is exactly like filmmaking
only it's one frame instead of 24 frames a second
so I only have to make one picture and I have
a lot more control and it's a lot cheaper and
I only need one model or a couple models and
I can do whatever I want and then I learned
photoshop and i'm like now I can really make
whatever I want composite people into crazy
locations because I need that creative outlet
as creatives like we have to feed the beast
so you you want that and that creature is hungry
and so you got to figure out ways to do it and
people I think that our creatives will find that
way either through writing or art or filmmaking
or basket weaving or whatever is on their Etsy
site you know you can find a creative outlet but
you kind of feel like you have to do it because
of this starving monster inside of you that needs
to be fed did you always honor that creature I
mean were there when you were growing up did you
have other plans for a quote-unquote career
did were there other classes you were taking
I never had a plan b like not really I really knew
very strongly what I wanted to do and thought that
it would be possible I think especially the late
90s like when I was in high school when DVDs first
came out they had these things called special
features which you never got on VHS tapes very
rarely would you get like a second VHS tape that
had like behind the scenes the only time you ever
get to see behind the scenes is on like a like
an entertainment news that would play for half an
hour a night you know before the sitcoms came on
or an HBO special or something so you never really
got to experience what it was like behind the
camera so I remember starting to see these special
features and being like oh man look at how they
make these movies like I didn't even think about
it as a kid I just thought these movies just came
out of nowhere they just poof existed but then
you see the whole processes and making that magic
happen and being a child and having so many movies
affect you as a kid and you know I i grew up as a
horror kid I mean I love slasher movies and some
people watch star wars I didn't watch star wars I
was an adult like I watched Freddie and Jason and
like this was where I like to escape to and horror
is a really is a really important thing to me too
the horror genre because a lot of people look at
as horror as like oh it's exploitive it's splatter
it's gross like why do you want to focus on like
horror doesn't focus on death horror focuses on
life you know you as a viewer survive no
matter what the movie there's people that
don't survive and it really lights a fire under
you hopefully to be like man I could have been
that guy that just took a machete to the head but
I didn't I lived I need to take advantage of this
there's such an inspiring me as a kid I was so
inspired because it's like oh look I lived no I
need to take advantage of this life while I have
it before some crazy hockey mask killer shows up
in the middle of the night and granted it's fun or
that a lot of them are fun but I always felt like
that it's an adrenaline rush it's like a roller
coaster and then at the end but you survive no
matter what and that's an exciting thing and
I like bringing up the audiences for sure.
What did you like about this video?